yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah this is a little update on my
banker repertoire this was released
roughly five weeks ago on chess table
and it they received a very nice nice
feedback here from the users and
actually am yeah it's the fastest under
fastest selling rapid to I ever watch
chest about 253 students at the moment
for the repertoire a very nice yeah very
nice and feedback from the users also um
yeah we see that there's a quite a long
discussion yeah you know the users very
nice we discussed the lights and and so
on there's something that I want to
stress again it's a living repertoire
way I'm corrections are made whenever
somebody points um yeah thing out that I
overlooked yeah in there are also
position comments so users post
questions and sometimes of course I make
mistakes and here for example you see
something I overlooked a possibility and
I changed this in the repertoire so we
have a living let's say a living product
it is not something that is totally set
in stone um one thing I want to point
out is and you don't actually see it in
this viewers i can actually let me log
out to get the regular of you from
jesibl here the Bangko repertoire is
currently on sale for 999 US dollars and
this is the introductory offer that only
is valid until november first which
means tomorrow this is the main reason
for posting this video so if you was
will if you actually had intended to
purchase that repertoire or chess ago
but you never really got to it and
forgot about it or whatever and you only
still have like one day left to benefit
from the cheaper 999
over it would be 14.99 14 point 99 here
from November second I'm not sure that's
probably a European time so if you want
to want to get it um yes it's best to do
it today or early tomorrow and no yeah I
think you won't be disappointed to have
people I really like the repertoire and
it's a they said it's a living living
thing that gets improved actually with
the users feedback so use its position
comments there are a couple of sites
like two or three pages it's not like
I've made so many mistakes but there
were some questions like why exactly the
smooth or things like that so it's a I
think it is a really nice product is on
sale now for serve one one day yeah
thanks guys bye bye